الان من لندن وجدان عبد الرحمن الاعلاميه
المختص في الشاني الايراني اهلا بك استاذ
وجدان نتحدث عن هذا الاعدام الذي نفذته
السلطات اذن الايرانيه في ما يوصف باول
اعدام على صله بالاحتجاجات ايوب رساله
توجهها السلطات في السياق هذه الاحتياجات
المتواصله في ايران
اعتقد انه هذه الرساله قبل ان تكون داخليه
هي رساله الى الخارج لان الدول خاصه الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي منها فرنسا منها المانيا
وايسلندا الذي همم طرحوا مشروع همم ادانت
ايران في مجلس حقوق الانسان وتشكيل
الاسنان ثالث
الدول لان لا نعتني باغراراتكم
نجدته من اجل البقاء لله الامر الثاني بكل
تاكيد هي رساله داخليه همم
المتظاهرين في الداخل الذي انا من
يقوم همم بعمليات اعتداء كما يصفونها همم
سيكون مصيرهم هكذا وهو اعدام للاسف الشديد
دول الغربيه بالتحديد الاوروبيه لم تاخذ
همم
مسؤولياتها باعتبارها الدول الداعيه لحقوق
الانسان والديموغرافيه
تتجاهل وتتعامل مع النظام الايراني منها
فرنسا من بدايه الثوره الى ايامنا هذا كم
قتل النظام الايراني وقام بعمليات
اغتيالات في على الاراضي الفرنسيه ومن ثم
فرنسا تقوم باطلاق
المجرمين هذا ما جعل النظام الايراني ان
يكون اكثر عدوانيا في الداخل وايضا اكثر
عدوانيه
كما يوصف بالنسبه للداخل الايراني وهناك
ايضا منظمات حقوقيه همم منظمات حقوق
الانسان في ايران ومقروها في خارج البلاد
التي ربما تحذر من ربما وتيره الاعدامات
التي ربما كانت تزيد فض الغياب رد ولي
قويه
فيما يتعلق بالجانب الاول من حضرتك موضوع
الاعدامات او هذا الاعدام لو كان يرضع
المحتاجين الى ما خرجوه بعد انتفاضه 2019
التي راحها ضحيتها اكثر من 1500 قتيل
وايضا هنالك العديد توفيق تحت التعذيب اذن
هذا الموضوع لن يرهب
المطالبين لان هناك حقوق خرج من اجلها
الشارع وقدم كل هذه الدماء همم
اعدام الاخير هو جزء من هذه التضحيات ما
انا اشهد ان الكثير من الاغتيالات يتم
تعذيب في السجون وهي ليس اقل قسوه من
الاعدام الذي همم فرض للاسف الشديد همم
لكن هذا لن يخيف منظمات حقوق الانسان همم
خارج هذه هي تقوم بعملها وما نشهدها اليوم
فرنسا 24 والقنوات الاخرى تركز على هذا
الموضوع بسبب المجهود الذي تقوم به هذه
المنظمات في الخارج جزيل الشكر لك يا
استاذ وجدان عبد الرحمن العلمي المختص في
شان الايراني حدثنا من لندن شكرا لك